hello everybody my name is naya and i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new
and inspiring software engineers and
today i want to just talk
a little bit more about my therapy
journey it's something
i have mentioned in the past and past
videos that
i've been going to therapy for a couple
of months now and yeah i just wanted to
just
sit down and talk to you all about how i
got here how i chose my therapist
and if you're looking into therapy just
what you may
expect in the process so yeah let's get
to it so i've been wanting to
get a therapist for a long time like
since i was a kid i remember asking my
mom like mom can i
have a therapist can i go see a
therapist because i just knew
that there were some things that i
wanted to actually talk through with a
professional
i have typically for a long time maybe
not always but for a very long time
had some anxiety problems or
issues or just you know my life has just
been
harder because of my anxiety levels at
times and
so as a kid i knew that like yo this is
not this is not
it and so i remember asking way back
when 4-1
but i ended up not getting one and come
college i
thought about it a lot more especially
with college where
there's so much change happening all at
once all of a sudden you're in this
whole new location
your family is nowhere to be found you
have all these new friends forming it's
just
so much that i knew specifically in
college like you i need i
need somebody to sit down with but
because
i you know i'm a college student so i'm
still on my
parents insurance at the time i was like
i don't want to talk about
i don't want them to know i don't want
them to know that i'm going to a
therapist so i come
from a zimbabwean background i was born
in zimbabwe and so there tends to be
that thought of oh they're they're going
to see a therapist
the okay what's cuckoo like it
tends to be that um yeah type of
sentiment around the idea of therapy and
so
i just didn't want to bring my parents
into it and i also didn't
just in general want them to ever ask me
about therapy how it's going or
i would just i know it's terrible i know
it's terrible i just wanted it to just
be
a me thing all to myself
and that was that and so throughout
college even though i
really really constantly thought about
it i decided to wait and was like you
know what
i'll wait until i have a job that way i
can
pay for it myself and i you know will be
on the jobs insurance will be off my
parents and they
just will never know now fast forward to
fall
of last year so fall of 2020 i started
having a bit more income
and more flexibility with my income i
got my own apartment
i was really just setting up the
building blocks of my life
and i have a friend of mine who sees a
therapist and she's very open with it
and
i asked her how it was going and she had
just switched
to a therapist who happened to be a
black woman
and so when she said this i was like oh
like
word i was like oh wow okay can i get
her information do you mind
if i get her information and you know
how is she you know first how
is she how do have you liked your
sessions um
and yeah do you mind if i get her
contact and all in all she's like no
it's been
good so far she enjoyed the experience
and so
i ended up contacting that therapist
that either that day or you know just a
few days
after now and this is what was very
rough was because i would have been you
know considered you know a new
patient it took a very long time for me
to actually get to see her in person
so my thing with therapy
and i think many people can share
the same feelings i do is for me
one of the hardest parts is finding
somebody not
in terms of the search itself but the
trial and
error of it of okay so i'm going to have
this one session
and we'll see if it's a match and if
it's not then i have another
session that's the exact same you know
of
me spilling my guts out all over again
seeing if they're
good fit if it's not then i do another
and it's just this
it's honestly just not a fun process
because you feel like you're going
nowhere you've done
five sessions and you're in the exact
same place as you were
a month ago because it's the same thing
over and over again because it's a new
person it's like dating you know like
it's a new person
they know nothing about you they need to
hear your story over and over again and
so that can be
just very emotionally tolling and so i
really did not want to do that so when
my friend said she had
you know been seeing this black female
therapist
i was like bet say no more and i really
just hopped on that
now i mentioned it took about yeah about
six weeks for me to see her for the
first time
that's really because and i didn't know
this um
and i maybe not every therapist is the
same in this regard
but from my understanding what will
happen
is you know therapists or mental health
you know specialist providers
counselors etc they have certain a
certain schedule based
around their quote unquote regulars then
they decide how
often to take in new people and so if
a counselor therapist specialist has
let's say a full eight-hour schedule
built out and
they really don't want to take a new
people it could be a very very long time
before you get to actually
see them for the first time then
when you finally get that first
appointment with your therapist and
you see that you would like to be a part
of their regular rotation
that's when you can see them kind of
anywhere anytime you want
every day and wait wait not every maybe
every day
but every week every other week twice a
week etc it's
a lot easier to build those types of
schedules and so that's why it took such
a long time for me to have just that
first appointment with my
therapist okay so something about me is
i do not like being new at something
and it's not that i don't like learning
new things or trying new things out
i don't like being a beginner in the
sense that
i have to train for this thing for
example training weeks oh my gosh
training for a job being their first
orientation or training week
i cannot stand it because i just want to
get to the work
you know what i mean i remember when i
was learning how to play guitar
i hated just the me being bad at it
because it means if i like a song i
can't just go straight in
and learn it right away i have to get
through all these other nooks and
crannies to even get to that point
same thing with therapy there's about
one to three weeks where
you're not even getting into the really
main
biscuits and gravy of why you're here
and everything you want to talk about
and your childhood traumas and things
like that you're kind of just getting to
know
one another or they're trying to just
know about you
my first session with my therapist they
had a questionnaire that they went
through
and we talked through the different
topics
in that question so for example one of
the questionnaire questions could be
i suffer from
abandonment yes no sometimes and then
the next question can be i
have a good relationship with my parents
yes no sometimes
so and of course there's a lot heavier
questions
that will be in that questionnaire i
just didn't want to bring those up here
but yes it's really more about setting
the stage
laying that foundation so that they also
know as a professional
really what they would like to tackle
first to make sure that you're
okay to make sure that you're
safe and so that was the first one two
three
for me personally it was the first two
sessions
where it was just going through these
this questionnaire
and so i didn't like that at all i
understand it's necessary please
believe me i understand it's necessary i
just didn't like it because
for me to be here you know
there's things i need to talk about so
badly with you
and so i remember making like a mental
note of
you know what the next time i let's say
switch therapists
or go through this situation again i
want to
book like three three sessions in just
one week
that way we can just get it all over
with and
i'm not a month in for the first time me
telling you about my problems
and yeah it's been a month and so i made
that mental note saying you know what
next time if i can i'm going to just
jam-pack all of this prerequisite
um questioning as much as i can
so that we get to the real mix of
everything
as soon as possible so i mentioned that
for the longest time
i didn't want to tell my parents that i
was seeking
the help of mental health professionals
and
for the first couple of sessions about
three sessions i paid them all out of
pocket
which for me it was
almost two hundred dollars per session
and
i after the third session i was like nah
this is not i was a finance major
naya this is not the financially
responsible thing to do
even if you make a million dollars if
you can
avoid spending something by just
saying i have insurance and saying
here's my insurance card or
just anything do it you know
and so i after that third session i was
like nah this is not
a responsible way to go like you're
trying to build your savings you're
trying to do x y and z
don't keep doing this i was willing
to budget that money out for this but i
was like
why you and you have insurance you have
the ability to not be paying this much
and so i sat down i was like okay
let's let me talk to my mother
and tell her that i'm seeking you know
mental health assistance and i am
going to be doing this for the you know
next i don't know 100 years of my life
and
if you see a charge to the insurance
his eye and that is why so
yeah i called my mom up and i made it
very
i was very matter-of-fact with it
because i didn't want any questions i
didn't want any questions i didn't want
any comments even i was like oh yeah and
by the way i
started seeing a therapist so if you see
a charge um that's
that's me so how was your sunday i i
left no room and so since then
since then that was really it to be
honest and i'm glad i did that
for you know i'm talking about mental
health but i also care about financial
well-being as well
and so i am glad i did that for that
um but i i'm i'm disappointed
that it took even three sessions for me
to be like nah this is your mental
health
if you had just sprained your ankle you
wouldn't be
oh i don't want it to show but yeah told
my mom hung up the phone
and now i pay 30 dollars per session
and it's different depending on your
insurance that's my um
like the co-pay is 30 some people could
be 50. it could be 60. it could be none
it could also be
none and it also can depend on how often
you go
and so for me i go once per week i've
been going for about six months now
and i asked i actually called the
insurance and asked them
let's say hypothetically i wanted to go
every single day of the week
would it still stay at 30 or is it a 30
co-pay as long as you don't exceed let's
say
six sessions a month and so that can
also be different
depending on your insurance and so if
you don't know or if you think you would
want
more frequent visits then i highly
recommend um just calling and asking
calling and asking my insurance actually
didn't take long i've had
longer calls with credit card companies
over you know stupid charges on my
cards than i did with the with the
insurance people asking them about
the therapy sessions so don't think it
has to be this crazy
half day gone thing it was a pretty
quick um
call maybe like five to ten minutes so
yeah i've been going for about six
months now
um let's see december
yeah i've been going for about six
months now and
i personally think it has start i think
it
is just now starting to help for the
first maybe three months i don't think
i saw much of a difference in me or
in my mental well-being and i i know
that's really odd
to say um but i'm just now starting to
see the
everyday impact it has where let's say
i'm going i'm getting stressed out and
then
i remember something you know my
therapist said or
i'm planning out my future and i
am less anxious about it because i know
that this is the mentality i'm having
now rather than
what it has been in the past and so it
had it did take a long time because
even after your first one to three intro
sessions you're still learning a lot
about each other you're still getting
your groove
together and it takes time to get to
that level of comfort of
sitting down and now me i sit down like
girl you won't believe
so it's like things like that i don't
say that but i'm just saying
it's now i'm now in a place where i'm
much more comfortable
with them where i can just be like yo
you won't believe
the things i just happened one thing i
also had to be patient about
is not letting my expectations
of what therapy would be like or what i
would get from my therapist
overshadow the experience itself and so
what i mean by that
is there would be times where i share
something
and i'm an overthinker and so i would
share something
and i'd be annoyed if the
if they didn't respond with oh well why
didn't why do you feel that way or no
how about we go into deeper or
what do you think and they wouldn't ask
those typical therapistic questions
because that was just what i
imagined you know and so i would get
kind of annoyed of like oh okay
she's not she's not gonna ask um okay
let me just tell her
or things like that but especially again
for the first few months you're still
trying to get a groove together
a lot of times they may just want to
just listen to you and see
how you tell stories how you recount
events how you speak about yourself and
others and really just taking that
in because they need to know the best
way
to guide you you know not everything
works for everybody
like yelling at one person may work but
yelling at me no
no so keep that in mind
if you are like me who has been thinking
about it for a while
and maybe an overthinker if your
expectation for the sessions don't match
what it is actually don't
pay too much don't put too much thought
into that especially if you're new
if you're new they really may just be
trying to get to know you
and understand how best to guide you
because now that it's six months in
now i'll kind of be stopped in my tracks
a little bit like oh
okay get with the hard questions i see
you
okay so so keep that in mind as
well yeah i think i'm gonna stop it
there before i start rambling and start
saying
you know things off the wall and whatnot
if you're not subscribed please
subscribe it helps me out a lot
like and comment if you liked it and no
i will see you
all later bye